1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10.
Il vincitore!
Che incontro, Johnnie!
Questa è la mano, la sinistra
È dinamite.
È la mano!
Un attimo, ragazzi.
Solo un minuto.
Bravo ragazzo!
Portiamolo al suo angolo.
Dai. Dai.
Di', sei un bravo manager.
Andiamo. Dov'è Johnnie? Dov'è?
Riprenditi. Stai bene?
Ragazzi, un po' di spazio.
Ehi, John, Andiamo, ragazzo.
Devi dire qualche parola al pubblico.
Non so cosa dire. Quello mi spaventa.
Oh andiamo. Di' qualcosa.
Mi senti, mamma?
Ho vinto, mamma, e non c'è un
segno su di me, nemmeno un segno.
Sarò presto a casa, tesoro,
ma non aspettarmi.
Ehi. Questa non è una linea privata.
Devi parlare al pubblico.
Bene, ciao gente.
Scusate, ma so che avreste detto le
stesse cose, con una mamma come la mia.
Comunque, voglio ringraziarvi per aver
tifato per me nella corsa al titolo.
Penso che siamo tutti contenti che sia
tornato negli U.S.A., dove deve stare.
Immagino che sia tutto.
Bravo, Johnnie!
Il nuovo campione!
Grande incontro, Johnnie.
Sei campione del mondo.
- Grazie, ispettore.
- Complimenti, Doc.
Vi dico, questo
ragazzo non sarà mai...
L' ispettore Ennis?
Laggiù.
E non ha mai più combattuto.
Oh, ciao, Phelan. Fatto?
Ho una sorpresa per te, campione.
Che è, il mio compleanno o altro?
Ti ricordi di questo?
Il mio orologio.
Sono contento che tu l'abbia trovato.
La mamma me lo regalò.
Risparmiò tutto l'anno per regalarmelo.
Ah ah!
Festa della mamma di nuovo.
Trovato in un banco dei pegni della 6ª
Avenue. Abbiamo preso anche il ladro.
Questo orologio vale per me più di
quella cintura che ho vinto.
Bel lavoro.
Non è merito mio. È stato Brewster.
Io l'ho consegnato.
Phelan è troppo occupato nel non
far fuggire i cadaveri dall'obitorio.
Non è vero, Monty?
Se lo dici tu, ispettore,
devi aver ragione.
Fai sapere a Doc chi è il
ragazzo e lui se ne occuperà.
Ti dispiace allacciarmelo, caro amico?
Non ci sono tasche in questo vestito.
No. L'altro polso.
Sicuro. Giusto. L'altro polso.
Avrei dovuto saperlo, sei un mancino.
- Primo buco.
- Puoi giurarci.
Primo buco.
Guarda che polso!
Sì. Credo di aver un bel polso.
Ho visto l'incontro stasera.
Hai combattuto in modo diverso.
Mancino con guardia destra.
È la prima cosa
che si nota di un uomo,
la sua posizione, più che la sua faccia.
Sai, molte persone si assomigliano,
ma mai due persone stanno
in piedi nello stesso modo.
Questa è una tua grande teoria, Phelan.
È così che hai identificato
Barney Scofield?
Sì, ispettore.
Farai meglio a tornare all'obitorio.
Quei morti possono dare problemi
se li lasci da soli troppo a lungo.
Ok, ispettore.
Uno nuovo?
Nuovo? Ah!
È al Dipartimento da quando ci sono io,
Solo che lui è all'obitorio,
mentre io sono ispettore.
Strano.
Sembrava un grande detective,
ha fatto ogni tipo di arresti
finché ha fatto quello sbagliato.
Parli di Phelan?
Sì. Ricordi che accusò Barney Scofield?
E scoprì lo sbaglio dopo che
andò sulla sedia?
Non scherzare, veramente?
Ok, Johnny. Fammi sapere
quando sei pronto.
Ho una scorta fuori per te.
Ok, ispettore, e grazie di tutto.
A posto, campione,
puoi portarti via la borsa.
Copritelo. Viene gente.
Ciao, Johnny.
Gran combattimento, ragazzo.
Molte grazie. Devo scappare ora.
I giornalisti mi aspettano.
Ho un impegno con loro.
È grande questo ragazzo.
Vince un campionato e
per primo pensa ai giornalisti.
E alla sua povera, vecchia,
madre.
♪ Per il milione di cose che mi ha
dato. Di cose che mi ha dato ♪
Pensi di essere divertente?
Smettila, Johnny. È brillo.
Non prenderla a male.
Non volevo dire nulla.
Ok.
Uno non beve, non scherza
sulle donne e rispetta la madre,
non per questo puoi prenderlo in giro.
- Non ascoltarlo, Johnnie. Gli altri
ti danno ragione. - Certo, Johnnie.
Buona notte.
Arrivederci, Johnnie.
Buonanotte, Johnnie.
Questo sì che è grande.
Ho ragione, o no?
Un grande!
Stasera la gioventù si è ancora imposta
quando Johnnie Bradfield
ha conquistato il titolo
nel settimo round
di un incontro programmato sui 15.
Johnnie combatte da campione.
I suoi colpi sono precisi e fulminei,
il suo sinistro è dinamite.
Dinamite rossa, direi.
Un po' di festa, Doc, eh?
Sì.
Vivere con la madre ed evitare alcol
e donne è il segreto del nuovo campione.
Lo dici tu,
ma ha ragione sulle donne, vero, John?
Nessuna donna nella vita del
campione, solo la piccola Goldie.
Sì.
Qual è il problema, Doc? Soffri
perché non hai la ragazza?
No. Non soffro.
Dai. Versaci da bere
Sì sì. Uno grande anche per me, Doc.
Hai già bevuto.
Dammene ancora.
Voglio la musica.
Dai. Stai allegro, Doc.
Sei il mio manager o no?
Abbiamo vinto il campionato. Abbiamo
fatto i soldi. Avrai molte donne.
Sì. Ecco.
Ho messo su qualcosa.
Dai. Dai. Alzati. Balliamo.
Dai. Alzati.
Voglio finire.
Non devi.
Dai. Balliamo, balliamo, balliamo.
Mettilo giù. Hai bevuto abbastanza.
Andiamo, balla.
Oh, no!
Oh, John, no!
Ah ah!
Ahhh!
7, 8, 9, 10. Ho buttato
giù Johnnie Bradfield!
Oh, sì.
Campanello
- Chi è ora?
- Forse è Budgie. Le ho detto di venire.
E perché?
Non preoccuparti. Non si trattiene.
Cara, eccoci qui.
Hai fatto bene a venire.
Il mio amico Charlie Magee.
Ciao. Entra. Voglio che conosci tutti.
Lui è Doc Ward.
Doc, Budgie Massey e il signor Magee.
Salve, Doc.
E questo è Johnny.
Johnnie! Oh, John, sono
felice di conoscerti.
Mi hai sentito urlare per te stasera?
Quasi mi facevo male, vero Charlie?
Certamente.
Johnnie, è per me?
È whisky Straight Rye.
Oh, posso berlo.
Ti avevo detto che potevo, vedi?
Perché le ragazze non possono fare il
pugilato? Qualcuno che vuole combattere?
Ehi, John. Johnnie,
vuoi combattere con me?
Ehi, John, Andiamo.
Mostrami come combattere.
Dai. Guarda il mio sinistro.
Buono, eh? Abbastanza buono, eh?
E il tuo?
Budgie, perché non ti calmi?
Sta zitto
Su. Colpiscimi campione. Sono
completamente scoperta.
Ahi! Vuoi smetterla?
Ooh, il campione non ce la fa.
Vuoi abbassare la voce, Budgie?
Sveglierai sua madre..
Lei ha il sonno pesante.
Sicuro. Ha il sonno tanto pesante...
Perché non vai a casa?
Oh, John, non fare così.
Budgie scherzava, non è vero tesoro?
Non mi piacciono questi scherzi.
Lei è suonata.
Non puoi parlare così ai miei amici.
Nessun amico, nessuno ha amici.
Vieni tesoro.
Dammi un altro drink.
Cosa intendi con "nessuno ha amici"?
Non sono tuo amico?
Sì, sei mio amico.
Al 50%, sei mio amico.
Non è così.
Sei mio amico perché sono
al top, ma non mi inganni
Potendo mi prenderesti soldi,
orologio, la mia ragazza.
Se fossi sobrio, non parleresti così.
E dai. È una partita persa in partenza.
Il mondo del pugilato?
Parlo di respirare, vivere.
Nessuno fa niente per niente.
- Sennò, sei un fesso.
- Tranne tua madre, eh?
Che ridere.
Mia madre. La mia cara, vecchia madre.
Non ho una madre.
Quella roba della madre è solo una
storiella, una storiella per fessi.
Questa è bella veramente.
Certo che lo è.
Come quella sull'alcol e le donne.
Bevo tanto e vado con tante donne.
E la madre non esiste!
Da morire.
Johnnie Bradfield non ha una madre.
Era solo una storia per i polli.
Una storia per il tuo giornale, Charlie?
Sì certo.
Cos'è questo?
Cosa dice?
Quel bastardo è un giornalista.
Giornalista?
Ehi, non stai allo scherzo, John?
Esatto, il "Morning graphic".
Non scriverai quello che ha
detto Johnnie?
Non dovrei? Hai una storia migliore?
Bene, arrivederci gente, e grazie.
Solo un minuto, Magee,
Fermati un attimo.
- Sì?
- Sì!
Voi andate a incipriarvi.
- Non farete nulla.
- No, se non servirà. Filate.
Ascolta, Magee. Non pubblicherai.
Sarei fesso a non farlo.
E io sarei fesso se non ti
picchiassi ogni volta che ti vedo.
Un minuto, Magee.
Non te ne stai ancora andando.
Oh!
Cosa succede? Johnnie!
Johnnie, sei ferito?
No. Sta bene.
Charlie!
Charlie, cosa ti hanno fatto?
Charlie. Charlie. Stai bene?
Santo cielo..
Che cosa?
Niente.
È morto.
È morto!
Siediti! Sta zitta!
- Perché lo hai fatto?
- Se lo è meritato.
Forza. Andiamocene.
- Non possiamo. Johnnie è svenuto.
- Dobbiamo. Prendi la tua roba.
Dai. Aiutami a tirarlo su.
- Ma dove andiamo?
- Da Mackey. Non c'è nessuno lì.
- Prendi cappelli e cappotti.
- Ok.
Entra prima.
Avanti.
Prendilo per un braccio.
Provaci a farmi fesso.
- Si è ripreso?
- No. È ancora morto per il mondo.
Magnifico. Facciamolo entrare in casa.
- Ecco. Fatti un goccio.
- Grazie.
- Ne avremo bisogno stanotte.
- Cosa vuoi dire?
Vieni qui.
Dobbiamo andarcene e subito.
- No. Io resterò. Devo.
- Resta. Se è quello che vuoi.
Doc, sei sicuro che sia stato lui?
Te lo ripeto, lo ha preso
con un sinistro,
e poiché non cadeva,
lo ha colpito
con una bottigliata sulla testa.
Poi è andato giù
ed è crollato anche lui.
La bottiglia? Non è da Johnnie.
Te lo ripeto, è un
killer quando è ubriaco.
Non so che farà
quella donna quando si sveglierà.
Ci siamo dentro tutti, anche io e te.
- Non abbiamo fatto niente.
- Sì? Eravamo lì, no?
Pensi che dirà che non abbiamo fatto
nulla? Pensi che si prenderà la colpa?
- Ma non abbiamo fatto nulla.
- Oh sta zitta. L'hai detto già.
Mi sono spiegato? Non conta "hai fatto
qualcosa?", conta "puoi dimostrarlo?"
Puoi provare che non hai fatto niente?
Beh, John non direbbe niente.
No. Lui andrebbe sulla
sedia per te, vero?
L'hai appena sentito dire
che non è uno stupido.
Dobbiamo restare uniti,
tu ed io, ragazza.
Diceva che avresti preso
i suoi soldi e l'orologio.
Sì, e la sua ragazza.
Non sono uno scemo.
Andiamo.
Uhh...
Oh!
Doc. Doc, ho paura.
Ho una paura matta.
Non c'è niente da temere, tesoro.
Attraverseremo il confine
e ci nasconderemo finché
tutto non sarà passato.
Andiamo.
Andiamo, Doc.
Sentiamo qualcosa di allegro.
Ok, piccola.
Numero di targa 2a-1243.
Ricercato Johnnie Bradfield, forse col
manager Ward e la ragazza, Goldie West.
Giornalista ucciso a casa sua.
Doc, ci stanno dietro. Non
farci prendere, Doc.
Va tutto bene, piccola.
Lo impedirò. Lo impedirò.
Fermate la Phaeton convertibile grigia
targata 2a-1243.
Sirena
Quei poliziotti ci danno la caccia.
BRADFIELD NUOVO CAMPIONE DEI
PESI LEGGERI PER K.O AL SETTIMO ROUND
GIORNALISTA UCCISO IN CASA DEL PUGILE
NUOVO CAMPIONE DEL MONDO
RICERCATO PER OMICIDIO
APERTA L'INDAGINE.
SCOMPARSI MANAGER E RAGAZZA.
Edizione straordinaria.
Assassino morto
in incidente. Leggete.
Giornale signore?
Assassino in fuga
morto in un incidente!"
Leggete tutte le informazioni.
ASSASSINO IN FUGA MORTO IN INCIDENTE
Santo cielo!
L'ASSASSINO DEL GIORNALISTA
E LA RAGAZZA BRUCIATI NELL'INCIDENTE
APERTE LE INDAGINI
MISTERO NELL'INCIDENTE: RIVELAZIONI
SORPRENDENTI DEGLI INVESTIGATORI
IRRICONOSCIBILE PER LE FIAMME JOHNNIE
BRADFIELD IDENTIFICATO DA UN OROLOGIO.
FUGGIVA CON LA RAGAZZA. IL CORPO
DEL GIORNALISTA SCOPERTO A SEGUITO
DI UNA TELEFONATA DI UNA DONNA DI NOME
BUDGIE CHE HA DETTO CHE BRADFIELD
HA COLPITO MAGEE CON UNA BOTTIGLIA
CAUSANDONE LA MORTE IMMEDIATA
Non l'ho colpito con una bottiglia.
Pensavo fossi morto.
No, non sono morto.
Perché parli così?
Hai ucciso quel Magee.
Non l'ho ucciso
Bene, ascolta. Che fai qui, allora?
Voglio chiederti
perché mi danno per morto.
L'orologio da polso.
Sì. Lo so. So leggere.
L'ho letto sui giornali.
Ha rubato il mio orologio, la
mia ragazza e la mia auto.
Eh, gli sta bene.
Mi dispiace per Goldie.
Lei era a posto.
Non mi avrebbe ingannato. È stato lui.
Ascolta. Lo sai che sei colpevole
di questo omicidio?
Cosa stai dicendo?
Volevo colpirlo, poi non ricordo.
Hai iniziato a colpirlo, ed è
morto, un giornalista.
Stai bene da morto.
Ma cosa dici!
Che cosa...
Ufficialmente, sei morto.
Tu sei quello bruciato in macchina.
Sei venuto qui per un consiglio.
Questo è il mio consiglio.
Lascia Johnnie Bradfield morto.
Tu sei qualcun altro,
Jack... Jack Dorney.
Ora esci da New York.
Sì, sì, ma io...
ho bisogno di soldi.
Ho diecimila dollari in banca.
Non puoi andarci. Non capisci?
Sono in una cassetta. Devo solo aprirla.
Ho la chiave. Nessuno mi vedrà.
Nessuno ti vedrà.
Dammi la chiave. Li prenderò per te
- Lo faresti?
- Certo, perché no.
Ecco. Vai a questo indirizzo.
Rimani lì finché non avrai mie notizie.
Non ti far vedere.
Non ho soldi. Non ho un centesimo.
- Ecco 10 dollari.
- Che farò con 10 dollari?
Cosa pensi?
Non devi mica andare al night.
- Ok., e quando ti sentirò, domani?
- Sì, domani.
- Questo è l'indirizzo?
- Sì.
- Non farti vedere da nessuno.
- Ho capito.
- Sennò sarai processato per omicidio.
- Non dirai sul serio, vero?
- Fai crescere la barba. Cambia aspetto.
- Ok. Farò qualcosa
Non credo che...
"Noi riteniamo che la morte di John
Bradfield e Goldie West
sia dovuta a cause accidentali
mentre sfuggivano all'arresto
per l'omicidio di Charles Magee."
I giornali non possono
starnazzare stavolta.
Uno viene ucciso e sei ore dopo,
non solo scopriamo chi
ha commesso il crimine,
ma sappiamo anche che è morto.
Immagina se ciò non fosse accaduto?
Capirai. L'omicidio di un giornalista.
- L'hai detto.
Bene, questo è quanto.
Posso parlarti, ispettore?
Sicuro. Hai un indizio
sull'omicidio Magee?
Proprio così. Non credo che quello
bruciato fosse Johnnie Bradfield.
Oh, sei pazzo.
Ricordi che misi
l'orologio al polso destro?
Il tizio bruciato l'aveva a sinistra.
E allora? Non può uno spostare
l'orologio da destra a sinistra?
Ci sono cose che uno
fa sempre allo stesso modo,
come il lato dal quale inizia a radersi
e il modo in cui inizia a vestirsi.
Lo stesso per l'orologio.
Phelan, sei stato troppo coi
cadaveri, hai le visioni. Proprio così.
Ti dico un'altra cosa.
Quell'orologio era nel terzo buco.
Quando l'ho allacciato al polso di
Johnnie Bradfield, l'ho messo nel primo.
Hai sentito che mi ha detto di farlo.
Quindi un polso è più grande dell'altro.
Non l'hai mai sentito?
Può essere.
Tutto quello che chiedo è
riaprire il caso e assegnarmelo.
Riaprire il caso?
Ora senti bene, Phelan.
Johnnie Bradfield ha ucciso Magee,
e Johnnie Bradfield è bruciato
stamattina alle 5.
- Adesso ascolta, capo.
- Ascolta chi?
Il problema è che
da quando hai mandato
l'uomo sbagliato sulla
sedia elettrica, hai avuto le visioni.
Sei matto.
Perché non vai in pensione?
Ti dirò perché.
Perché non sono finito.
Oh, sì, lo sei, ma non lo sai.
- La vedremo se sono finito. - Sì? Come?
Dimostrerò che quel tizio
non è Johnnie Bradfield.
- Lo farai, eh?
- Fammi provare. Hai paura?
- Chi, io?
- Sì! Tu!
Per 10 anni mi hai preso in giro
perché ho fatto un errore.
Forse questo è il tuo errore.
Forse se lo provassi, ti manderebbero
all'obitorio come hai fatto con me.
Mi piacerebbe vederlo.
Va bene, Phelan.
Hai trovato un incarico.
Grazie, ispettore.
Ora, riportalo vivo o morto.
Cosa vi avevo detto, ragazzi?
È un matto, solo un matto.
- Sono due giorni che ti chiamo.
- Ero occupato.
- Voglio andarmene. Hai i miei soldi?
- Sì. Eccoli.
50, 100,
150, 200, 250.
- Cosa sono questi?
- I tuoi.
Che vuol dire "tuoi"?
Ora, se fossi in te,
metterei molta
distanza tra me e questa città...
Dove sono i miei soldi, i diecimila?
I tuoi 250. Il
resto è la mia parcella.
Cosa dici? Dov'è il
resto dei miei 10 mila?
Te l'ho detto. È la mia parcella.
Stai cercando forse di farmi fesso?
Chi pensi che io sia?
Dammi il resto di quei 10.000 o io..
Cosa vuoi? Bene, andrai sulla sedia.
Ora ascoltami, ti darò un consiglio.
Non usare i pugni, o sei fritto.
Se prendi quella posizione
insolita da guardia destra,
qualcuno ti riconoscerà.
Pare che tu non capisca, Dorney...
- Cosa?
- Jack Dorney. Ricordatelo?
Jack Dorney.
Pensi di poterlo ricordare?
Jack... Dorney.
- Come dicevo, Dorney...
- Dorney.
Non assumere quella posizione.
Non usare mai i pugni. Mai.
Ucciderai un altro uomo,
o se non lo farai, ti farai scoprire.
Ti farai scoprire.
Se ti prendono, la
tua vita non vale nulla...
Lo ripeto, Jack Dorney.
Stai lontano da posti frequentati. Da
ogni posto, fuori di vista, timoroso.
D'ora in poi devi avere paura.
- Hai capito?
- Sì. Sì. Ho capito.
Questo è il mio consiglio, e
vale diecimila dollari. Ecco.
Ora vattene, stupido.
Cosa posso fare con questi?
250 dollari?
Possono durare molto, cosa vuoi di più?
Non vorrai andare in treno fra la gente.
Non vorrai usare un'auto.
Salti su un merci che non ti costerà
nulla e ti tieni i soldi per mangiare.
Dovrebbero durare almeno 6 mesi.
CAMERE A 50 e 75 CENTESIMI
LETTI A 15 CENTESIMI
Ehi, hai il piede sui miei soldi.
È qui che ti sbagli, amico.
Questi sono i miei soldi, non i tuoi.
Ehi, aspetta un attimo.
Vacci piano, Mel.
Sta zitto.
Qualche problema?
Niente.
Fatti una passeggiata.
DATTERI
RANCHO RAFFERTY
Ehi, Peggy.
Ehi, Peggy. Vieni qui.
Che c'è?
Guarda. Un altro vagabondo.
Ehi, vedi quel tizio?
Pensa... un albero in meno da spogliare.
Sarebbe bello, eh?
Solo un altro vagabondo dalla città.
Cosa ne pensi?
Ehi! Che fai?
Guarda. Abbiamo compagnia.
Una signora? Dov'è?
Nessuna donna, sei brillo. Perché
non la smetti? Mi prendi in giro.
Mi chiedo se c'è una possibilità...
Sì. C'è ne una grande.
C'è una scala là dietro
e alcuni cestini e dei datteri,
Se riempi 3 cesti, avrai da mangiare.
Non sono un vagabondo.
Lo so. Sei un grande petroliere, e sei
venuto qui per studiare l'anticlinale.
Suppongo che tu abbia una limousine.
Supponi che io ti dicessi
che ne avevo una, anzi due.
Guarda. Conosco tutte le storie,
ma se vuoi mangiare,
devi raccogliere.
Mi sa che non si mangia bene qui.
Va bene per me.
Sai, il Waldorf è proprio
dietro l'angolo.
Dovresti provare il caviale.
Grazie. Sono goloso di caviale.
Nonna!
Nonna Rafferty!
Presto!
Cosa c'è?
Oh! Oh!
Eccoci. Cosa c'è?
È svenuto.
Portiamolo via. Non può stare qui.
Adesso attenzione, sta cadendo.
Dai. Adesso alzatelo.
Goldie. Sei tu, Goldie?
No, non sono Goldie.
Dove sono? Dov'è Doc?
Vacci piano, amico.
Voglio sapere.
Sei al Rancho Rafferty,
circa 20 miglia da
Colinga, Arizona,
se questo significa qualcosa per te.
Arizona.
Sì.
Sì sì sì. Capisco.
Mi hanno contato...
Conteggio lungo, direi.
Sei stato out per due giorni.
Dove sono stato colpito?
Nello stomaco
Non mangerai da una settimana.
Ecco.
Cos'è?
È latte. Ne hai mai sentito parlare?
Certo, certo.
Ne fanno manici per ombrelli.
- Bello e tranquillo qui, vero?
- Mmh.
Nessuno in giro?
No. Solo io, la nonna e i ragazzi.
Cosa fai da sola tutto il giorno?
Ranch.
Non capisco Non sei il tipo che...
No.
Non sembri la figlia di un fattore.
Senti. Vuoi dirmi qualcosa di te?
Va bene.
Se lo rifai, sei out per una settimana.
Te l'ho detto che non sono Goldie.
Non puoi arrestarmi per averci provato.
Bene, eccoci qui.
- Ciao, Peggy.
- Salve sceriffo.
- Come stai?
- Bene, credo.
Bene. Oh.
Quindi questo è il giovane
che è svenuto, eh?
Sì, sceriffo. Questo è il ragazzo.
Da dove vieni, ragazzo?
Texas. Io tagliavo laggiù.
- Gole?
- Oh, no. Manzo.
Conosci qualcuno qui?
No, no, no. I miei sono in Texas.
Cercavo solo lavoro qui finché
le cose là non si sistemeranno.
Lasciamo il ragazzo
tranquillo, sceriffo.
È rimasto incosciente due giorni.
Certo certo. Bene.
Vado per la mia strada ora.
Voglio solo vedere i ragazzi.
Devo fare il mio rapporto
al dipartimento, lo sai.
Eh, come se gli importasse.
Sceriffo, che dice. Le faccio una foto?
La mia foto? Perché no?
Ok. Qui fuori dove c'è luce.
È un bel giovanotto.
Sì. È probabile che vada via
appena potrà camminare.
Ah Ah Ah!
Ehi, dove stai andando?
Cosa fai, scroccone?
Stai andando a lavoro?
Ehi, nonna, Peggy!
Stai zitto, tu.
Perché, tu grande...
- Un attimo, bastardo. In guardia.
- Vattene, o ti farai davvero male.
Bella cosa colpire
un ragazzo che è la metà di te.
Ti riempirei di sberle.
Oh, l'ho solo toccato.
Non si può fare una passeggiata senza
che un ragazzino si metta a strillare?
Quindi scappavi senza
dire una parola a nessuno.
Non vorrà che resti bloccato qui, vero?
Ho detto che cercavo lavoro.
Sono 20 miglia per la città più vicina.
Lascialo andare. Lo sceriffo
ha posto per i vagabondi.
Ripeto, cerco lavoro. Non possono
farmi nulla per questo.
Parli come se fossi un criminale.
Cerca qui. Se è lavoro che cerchi,
ce ne è molto qui vicino.
Capisco. Mi avete ospitato.
Ora volete che vi ripaghi, eh?
Come potrei chiederlo a un lazzarone
vagabondo con una faccia come la tua.
Cosa vuoi che faccia?
Bene, finché non prendi un po' di
colore in quella tua faccia,
puoi sederti al sole
e far divertire i ragazzi.
Bah.
Far divertire i ragazzi?
Ah ah ah! Ah ah!
Non ci siamo divertiti.
- Ehi. Sei di New York, vero?
- Sì. Ero lì.
Mi manca l'East river.
Anche il riformatorio dove dovevi
finire. Ti manca eh?
Il riformatorio non è così male.
Mio fratello c'è stato due volte.
Non esce finché non ha 21 anni.
Sì. Ha un contratto d'affitto là.
Come mai siete qui?
Scottavamo a New York. Così
ci hanno mandato qui per rieducarci.
Sì? Chi è stato?
Padre Rafferty. Ne hai mai
sentito parlare?
Mai stato nella mia chiesa.
Nella mia neanche. Comunque,
era un prete sulla riva est
Finché è morto circa un anno fa.
È suo il fondo "Aiuta il tuo vicino"
che manda i ragazzi difficili a sua
sorella, quella signora.
Perché?
Per degenerarli.
Rigenerarli, rimbambito! Rigenerarli.
Significa rieducati.
Un riformatorio per ragazzi, eh?
Sì, ma non mi hanno rigenerato
perché sto per tornare sulla riva Est.
Come ci vai, in pullman,
o prenderai un aereo speciale?
Chiederò un passaggio, Joe.
Come lui.
Eh, non ne hai il coraggio.
Non lo hai.
Chi è la signora?
La sorella di Tommy.
Sì? E lei cosa ha fatto?
Lei non ha fatto nulla.
Dovrebbe controllare
che Tommy "degeneri".
- Rigeneri!
- E smettila.
Il giudice lo mandava al riformatorio,
se non prometteva di sorvegliarlo,
finché non "degenerava"
Sta zitto!
Ehi! Cosa vuoi fare, uccidermi?
No, solo tagliarti la gola.
Sai, Tommy è un ragazzo difficile. Lo
hanno sorpreso a rubare in un magazzino.
Io sono stato beccato a squarciare gomme
a Cherry Street, in un garage.
- Hai un fiammifero?
- Cosa hai lì?
Foglia di mais. Ne vuoi una?
No. Sapete
dove trovare sigarette vere?
Sì. Le vendono alla bancarella.
Sì? Bene, a che serve fumare erba
quando puoi fare diversamente?
No. Non ruberebbero nulla qui intorno.
Nessun furto per me.
Pensavo che foste dei duri.
Aspetta un minuto.
E tu? Hai paura?
Paura? Non ho paura di nulla
Rubare sigarette non fa per me,
tutto qua.
Lascialo stare.
Aspetta un minuto.
Ti sfido a prendermene un po'.
Coraggio. Osa.
Devi prendere coraggio.
Ehh.
Ehi, non vuoi osare?
Tommy, devi prendere coraggio.
Posso avere qualcosa da bere?
Sì. Sì. Ci penso io.
- Ecco qui.
- Oh, grazie.
Proprio quello che ci voleva.
- Prese, ragazzo?
- Sì. Ecco qui.
Bel lavoro. Grazie.
Veramente un bel lavoro
mandare i ragazzi a rubare per te.
Se c'è qualcosa di peggio
non mi è ancora capitato.
Dai. Boxate. Avanti.
Dai! Colpiscilo al volto, Angel!
Boxate. Combattete.
Avanti!
Cosa stai aspettando?
Andiamo. Avanti. Avanzate.
Avanti.
Separatevi, ragazzi!
Qual è il problema?
Eh, attento.
Boxate. Combattete.
Ragazzi, ragazzi, combattete.
Colpiscilo con quel destro, Tommy.
Forza ragazzi. Combattete.
Dai. Avanti. Combattere.
Colpiscilo forte.
Aah!
Scorrettezza! Scorrettezza!
Scorrettezza!
Cosa ho fatto?
Sta zitto.
Ehi, l'hai visto, vero?
Non abbiamo visto nulla.
Era una scorrettezza.
Non può dire il contrario.
È scorrettezza quando l'arbitro vede.
Certo. Conosco il regolamento ufficiale.
Macché...
Aah! Piantala, tu...
Fatti furbo, fai così.
Vieni qui. Ti farò vedere.
Ecco, Tommy. Stai in guardia.
Tieni avanti il destro
e fai così.
Mentre muovi il destro
fingi un gancio, e lo colpisci
con il gomito sinistro. - Ohhh!
Sì, ma non è corretto.
Ma non lo è se l'arbitro vede.
Il trucco è mettere l'altro tra
te e l'arbitro così non ti vede.
Dai, Jack. Boxiamo.
Eh, io non ne so niente.
Oh, lo dici tu. Dai.
Dai, Jack.
Colpiscilo dritto negli occhi.
Attento al destro, Tommy.
Al destro.
Cosa fai?
Stavo solo scattando la tua foto.
Fermati. Non farlo mai più, capito?
Ma che cosa hai?
Non importa,
ma smettila con quella macchinetta.
Ok ok.
Perché te la prendi, Jack?
Dai. Dai, Jack.
Dai, Jack. Mostraci altri trucchi
Vai. Dagli di gomito.
Colpiscilo con il destro.
Dai con quel destro, Tommy.
Dai. Alzati e...
Guarda. Se non vuoi che resti in piedi
dagli il pollice nell'occhio.
Ahi! Capisco.
Solo più forte e più veloce,
Ma assicurati che l'altro
sia tra te e l'arbi..
Ok, ragazzi. Filate. Filate.
Accidenti, Peggy, stai
sempre in mezzo.
Perché non lasci soli noi uomini?
Stai sempre in mezzo ai piedi.
Insegnavo solo al
ragazzo come difendersi.
Sì, con sporchi trucchi.
Qualcuno li farà con lui, e
imparerebbe a farli per primo.
Non credi che ci sia qualcosa
di onesto, vero?
- E tu?
- Io so che non ci credi.
- Bene, e io?
Tu fai l'agente di sorveglianza, no?
- E allora?
- Ci guadagni?
- No.
- Non me la bevo.
So tutto di quel prete a New York.
Lui è morto.
Sì? E il fondo?
Non c'è alcun fondo.
È finito quando è morto.
Vuoi dirmi che tu e la signora
aiutate questi ragazzi gratis?
- È così.
- Perché?
Non capiresti.
Eh, devi avere un secondo fine.
Mi chiedo se sei così duro
come pensi di essere.
Non sono così duro, ma
neanche un fesso.
Chi sarebbe un fesso?
Sei fessa se quello che dici è vero.
Così quella signora. Così quel prete.
- Perché danno una mano?
- "Aiuta te stesso" è il mio slogan.
E cosa te ne viene?
Bene, un sacco di cose.
Grazie per la lezione.
"B-16.
Serbatoio monocomponente
da 500 galloni, ignifugo.
1.938 dollari installato."
E allora?
- Tommy vuole aprire
una stazione di servizio. - Sì? Dove?
Oh, di fronte al negozio.
Tommy è diventato responsabile.
Sì. Dovrò pure prendermi
cura di mia sorella, o no?
Che problema ha? Andava bene
l'ultima volta che l'ho vista.
È preoccupata per il ranch. Solo se
vende molti datteri copre le spese.
Siamo in arretrato sulle tasse da quando
il denaro non arriva da New York.
Potrebbe perdere il posto in poco tempo.
- Chi te l'ha detto?
- La nonna e lei parlano solo di questo.
Sì. L'ho sentite anche io.
E allora? Chiudiamo il ranch e torniamo
a New York. Non sarebbe male.
Non c'è un benzinaio sulla strada per 42
miglia da una parte e 28 dall'altra.
Circa 200 auto al giorno passano nei
giorni feriali e il doppio la domenica.
Potremmo mantenere
il ranch vendendo benzina.
Sembra che sia "degenerato", eh?
Quanto costerebbe
la stazione di servizio?
Oh, circa due mila.
Bene, come pensi di fare per i soldi.
Pensa di rapinare una banca
quando sarà più grande.
Oh sta zitto. Non è divertente
Ehi, fa troppo caldo per sognare.
È il serbatoio di cui parlavi?
Sì! È così! L'East river dell'Ovest!
Ascoltate, ragazzi.
Dopo tanto siamo arrivati a
quel ranch che stanno irrigando.
Abbiamo perso la cognizione del tempo.
Chi dice che abbiamo fatto
il bagno passa i guai, capito?
Bene. Jack.
- L'ultimo che arriva è un codardo!
- Di più, un fesso!
Zitto! Vuoi che il vecchio
Henry ci corra dietro?
Tranquillo. Abbiamo tutto il giorno.
Fammi entrare in acqua.
Andiamo!
Questa è vita. Sto arrivando.
Eccomi!
- Com'è l'acqua, Jack?
- Stupenda!
- Yahoo!
- Aspettami!
Arriva il campione olimpico!
Piccolo!
Perché non entri?
Di cosa hai paura?
Io non ho paura.
Ehi, viene dall'Ottava Strada.
Nessuno di loro sa nuotare.
Chi non sa nuotare?
Ti farò vedere.
Ragazzi, guardate
quanto è bassa l'acqua.
Riesco solo a toccare la cima.
Staranno "irritando".
Irrigando, tonto, irrigando.
Ok ok. Irrigando.
Ehi, Jack! Non riesco
a raggiungere la cima!
Jack, è meglio che lo aiuti
perché non sa nuotare molto bene.
Ok, ragazzo. Adesso va.
Oh, Jack! Alzami!
Sta zitto. Che hai?
Voglio salire!
Va bene adesso?
Certo che va bene. Dai.
- Ehi, Jack! L'acqua sta finendo.
- Lo so. Lo tieni?
Tommy, vieni qui.
Dippy, reggi Angel.
Vado giù, ti sollevo dalle caviglie
sino in cima, e tu ti aggrappi.
Ok. Andiamo.
Pronto?
- Riprova. Sei pronto?
- Sì, sono pronto.
Spit, sicuro di dirmi la verità?
Ti do la mia parola.
Davvero, Peggy, non so dove sono andati.
Non hanno detto dove andavano?
- Hanno preso il furgone e sono andati.
- Quanto tempo fa? - Circa un ora.
È a 10 piedi e ancora scende.
Tutto ciò che dobbiamo
fare è restare uniti
e aspettare che l'acqua scenda e
possiamo toccare. Vi state stancando?
No. No.
Ehi, Jack!
L'acqua ha smesso di scendere.
- Sei sicuro?
- Sì. È ancora allo stesso livello.
Cosa facciamo adesso?
Ehi!
Vado giù a vedere
cosa c'è in fondo a questo serbatoio.
- Potete tenerlo per qualche minuto?
- Sì. Lo terrò io.
Non lasciarmi andare, Tom.
C'è una valvola laggiù che fa uscire
l'acqua, ma bisogna tenerla aperta.
Andrò io questa volta.
Prendi il ragazzo.
Ok. Eccomi.
Non posso resistere molto a lungo.
Va tutto bene, Tommy.
Penso che sia scesa.
Tienilo?
Ci provo.
Calma, ragazzo. Calmati.
L'hai fatto?
Ho toccato il fondo.
Bisogna farlo ancora una volta.
Vai, Jack.
Oh, Peggy, stiamo cercando dappertutto.
Non riusciamo a trovarli.
Sì. Abbiamo battuto tutta la strada.
Nonna, non dovevano
andare in città col furgone.
Non ti preoccupare, Peggy.
Forse il furgone si è rotto.
Stanno bene.
Questa è una buona idea. Andiamo. Su.
Ecco. Su!
Ora Tommy e Angel.
Prendi quella
scala e buttala giù.
Ok ragazzi.
Dai.
Sì. Presto.
Va bene, ragazzi. Salite.
Così.
Aspetta fino a quando arriva su.
Ehi, questo ragazzo sputa
acqua come una fontana.
Tienilo giù.
Queste buche gli faranno bene.
Johnnie, pensi che sia annegato?
No, no. Starà bene.
Ora ascoltate. Nessuno parli, capito?
Si è allontanato, è caduto
in acqua, l'abbiamo salvato.
- Capito? - Capito. - Sicuro.
Non li vediamo dalle due
di questo pomeriggio.
Sono andati via col furgone.
Non lo so, sceriffo.
Non so dove sono andati.
Cosa dice?
Ehi guarda. Arrivano.
Non importa, sceriffo.
Sono appena arrivati. Grazie.
Dove siete stati?
Abbiamo preso il
furgone e siamo andati
dove irrigavano quel nuovo ranch, e
ci siamo fermati a guardarli, e...
Sì, e prima di rendercene conto, si
stava facendo buio. Non è vero, Angel?
Sì.
Tu sei tutto bagnato!
Prendi degli asciugamani,
presto, e un brandy.
Vieni al fornello e scaldati.
Bene, cosa gli hai fatto?
È caduto in un canale di irrigazione.
Sì certo. È vero.
Siete caduti tutti nello
stesso canale?
Sì. Ci siamo bagnati per tirarlo su.
Ci sono i telefoni, lo sapete.
Non dove eravamo.
Non mi aspetto la verità da te
o da qualcuno di loro finché sei qui.
In effetti, ne abbiamo
abbastanza di te. Vattene.
- Va bene per me. Quando vuoi che vada?
- Prima è meglio è.
Vado via subito, se è questo che vuoi.
- Peggy, tu non sai cosa lui...
- Sta zitto.
Andiamo.
Non è giusto, te lo dico. Non lo è.
Eh, va bene.
Eccoci qui, come gatti in trappola.
- Vuoi dire topi.
- Voglio dire gatti. Tu lo sai, Jack.
Come quando affoghi
dei gattini in un secchio.
Sicuro. È giusto.
- Siamo sul "baratto" della morte.
- Baratro..
Ah, la smetti? Ogni volta mi fai
innervosire. Pensa sia bene per me?
Comunque, nell'acqua,
rischiavamo la morte.
- Saremmo tutti morti se non c'era Jack.
- Sicuro. Ovviamente. Certamente.
Perché non vuoi che glielo diciamo
Direbbe che è stata
colpa mia per avervici portato.
- Non pensi di portare qualcuno con te?
- Chi? Chi intendi? Te?
Molti giornalieri viaggiano insieme.
E la stazione di servizio?
Può aspettare finché non
guadagno abbastanza soldi per tornare.
Mi piacerebbe portarti, ma tua sorella
mi farebbe ricercare per rapimento.
- Beh, pensavo solo che...
- Certo, Tommy, e lo apprezzo.
Ancora ti immischi, eh? Non hai già
causato abbastanza problemi oggi?
Mi piacerebbe parlare
con Jack da solo.
Ok, ragazzi. Filate.
Cosa ti passa per la testa?
Niente, John, salvo...
Bene...
Angel mi ha detto la verità su
quello che è successo.
Ho detto che mi dispiaceva, no?
Ti ho dato del mascalzone, ma
credo che tu sia un eroe.
Ti prepari per un'altra rissa?
No. Penso che tu sei a posto.
Certo. Non sono cattivo.
Te l'ho detto prima.
Lo so. Così diceva la nonna, ma
non ci ho creduto fino ad ora.
Non devi andartene, a
meno che tu non voglia.
Sai,
c'è solo una ragione per
cui voglio stare qui...
Tu.
Vuoi che rimanga?
Bene, questo è quanto.
Appena ti sei lavato e vestito
e tutto il resto,
ti piacerebbe portarmi in città?
Ho alcune commissioni.
D'accordo.
Allora è meglio
che mangi qualcosa, mentre mi cambio.
15 minuti.
Pensi?
No.
Senti, conosco un posto sulla
strada dove non passano mai auto.
Supponiamo di parcheggiare e...
parlare.
Perché?
Sono pazzo di te.
Non è abbastanza?
Sì. È molto,
ma inizia nel modo sbagliato.
Come nel modo sbagliato?
Beh, non so niente di te
O chi sei, tranne il tuo nome,
E forse non è il tuo nome.
Sembra come se stessi
proponendo il matrimonio.
Che cosa stai proponendo?
Oh, niente del genere.
Oh.
Beh, sei sincero, almeno.
Perché non sei sincera anche tu?
Vuoi?
Sicuro. Va bene.
Sei un bell'uomo...
Grazie gentile.
- Con il cuore giusto...
- Ahh.
Ma la testa sbagliata.
Perché cerco di fare l'amore con te?
No. Perché stai cercando di
fuggire per un omicidio.
Sai, vengo dalla grande città
e ne ho sentite tante.
E quindi devo pensare
a un'altra storia, eh?
Non sarebbe male
Ok. Penserò a un'altra storia.
Aspetterò.
Ciao, Jack! Ciao, Peggy!
Ciao, Speed.
Fai benzina.
Vado dal ferramenta per parlare col
signor Hayman di alcuni affari.
- Torno fra un minuto.
- Bene.
Il pieno?
Sì, quella economica.
Perché non prendi quella buona stavolta
così puoi provare la mia nuova pompa?
Se mettessi buona benzina in questo
catorcio, probabilmente esploderebbe.
Di', un po' di olio? È appena arrivato.
Sì? Quanto?
30 centesimi.
30 centesimi? Sono troppi.
IL TORO SELVAGGIO D'EUROPA
GASPAR RUTCHEK
TOUR IN U.S.A.
AFFRONTA OGNI AVVERSARIO
A BREVE QUI
SABATO 25 SETTEMBRE ORE 20.00
500 DOLLARI A ROUND
SARANNO PAGATI AD OGNI SFIDANTE
CHE RIMARRÀ IN
PIEDI OLTRE DUE ROUND.
Ehi, ti iscrivi?
Ho sentito che è forte.
Se fosse forte, non girerebbe
per le campagne.
Deve essere abbastanza forte,
se offrono 500 dollari
a chiunque riesca a resistergli.
Sono un sacco di soldi.
Sì. Penso proprio che sia un
sacco di soldi.
Non abbastanza
per tentarmi, però.
No?
Non entrerei sul ring con quel grosso,
brutto alce per 5.000 dollari a round.
"Toro selvaggio d'Europa".
Sembra un assassino.
Tutto pronto?
- Otto galloni. Un dollaro e 28 cents.
- Segna.
Jack, quel conto sta diventando
un po' alto. Pagami stavolta.
Eh, di cosa ti lamenti?
Sarai pagato... prima o poi.
Ok. Lo faccio per Peggy e la signora
fino a quando le cose andranno meglio.
Questa è una bella pompa.
Ti va bene il lavoro, vero?
Non posso lamentarmi. Quando devono
fare benzina, devono farla.
Quanto ti è costata la pompa, due mila?
Quasi, è un grande miglioramento
rispetto alla vecchia.
Senti. Mi assento pochi minuti. Se
arriva Peggy, dille che torno subito.
Va bene.
Non sei abbastanza grosso,
sei troppo leggero
Che c'entra se io voglio?
Non mi preoccupi te. I clienti
non pagano per incontri combinati.
Gli darò molto filo da torcere.
Gestisco un incontro, non un omicidio.
Vai. Fila.
- Ho un sacco di lavoro.
- Ascolta. Voglio una possibilità.
Vattene. Fila. Sono occupato.
Stai lontano, o ti do un gancio.
Oh, lo farai?
Ooh!
Allora. Lo faccio quell'incontro, o no?
Sì. Lo farai.
Sarà un piacere.
Che c'è? Qualche pensiero?
Pensavo che Tad Hayman ci avrebbe dato
un anticipo sul raccolto,
ma anche lui è al verde quest'anno.
Non preoccuparti.
I tuoi problemi sono finiti.
Apriremo una stazione di servizio.
- Una stazione?
- Sicuro.
Come ti è venuto in mente?
Beh, statistica.
Non c'è una stazione di servizio per
42 miglia in un senso e 28 nell'altro.
Hai idea di quanto costa?
Oh, mi sono informato.
Hai sentito del grande incontro
al Legion Stadium fra due settimane?
Di quel buffone che offre 500 dollari a
round a chi resisterà per più di due?
Sì. Ho letto qualcosa.
Bene, io vado e combatto.
Devo solo restare in piedi per 4 round.
4 volte 500... Sono 2000 dollari.
C'è l'ho in tasca.
Ma, Jack, sei pazzo.
È un professionista.
Ti farebbe molto male.
Chiunque pensasse di resistere a
uno come quello sarebbe...
Un fesso?
Sì, un fesso.
E se mi facessi male,
sarebbe importante per te?
Sì, Jack, lo sarebbe...
Molto.
Questo volevo sapere.
Con te a tifare per me, andrò lì e
farò secco il più forte del mondo.
ZONA DI ALLENAMENTO DI JACK DORNEY
VIETATO L'ACCESSO
Destro. Destro, sinistro, destro!
Oh, smettila!
Fallo fuori!
Dai! Rompigli la testa!
Picchialo! Che pugile!
Non potrai resistere mezzo
round con i piedi così.
Non puoi fermare un camion se sei
così lento. Avanti! Veloce! Salta!
Ma che ne sai tu?
Tanto, grande,
grasso, stupido maldestro.
- Come va il fiato?
- Il mio fiato? Oh, tutto bene.
Ah, lo scoprirò.
Vai ora. Colpiscilo. Non farci l'amore.
Colpiscilo, ti dico.
Colpiscilo! Così.
Lavori duro?
Sì. Una cosa che mi piace.
Lo inciti, Peg?
Non disturbatelo mentre si allena.
- Fatti gli affari tuoi.
- Sono affari miei, lo alleno.
Affari tuoi? Da quando lo alleni?
Dai, Jack. Ancora 3 minuti, e smettiamo.
BAGNO PRIVATO DI JACK DORNEY
PUBBLICO NON AMMESSO
♪ Da una cascata
io chiamo You-oo-oo-oo
da una cascata... ♪
Ehi, sbrigati con quell'acqua.
Vacci piano, Caruso. Durerà più a lungo
Com'è l'acqua, campione?
Brr. Dove l'hai presa così calda?
♪ Da una cascata, ti
chiamo oo-oo-oo a ♪
Ehi, ragazzi! Guardate un po' qui.
- Cosa hai?
- Ho appena vinto 3 dollari.
Che dici, 3 dollari?
La gara fotografica "Salt lake times".
Ecco i 3 dollari se non mi credete.
- Andiamo. Mostraci la foto. Dov'è?
- Sì certo.
Dai. Tirala fuori.
Guarda. Proprio qui.
Ma guarda chi c'è! È Jack!
Jackie. Ehi, Jackie, guarda.
C'è la tua foto sul giornale.
Ma che dite?
- Quando l'hai presa?
- Una volta che non guardavi.
Pensavo di averti detto di non farlo.
Cosa ti avevo detto sulle foto?
Oh, che male ho fatto?
Dovrei gonfiarti per questo,
piccolo imbroglione.
Lasciami andare. Non ho fatto niente.
Ho guadagnato 3 dollari, no?
Eh, sta zitto.
CONCORSO FOTOGRAFICO AMATORI
Ma guarda come tende
la sua mano destra.
Quindi un tizio esce dalla tomba,
tende la sua destra così puoi arrestarlo
e provare che noi altri siamo idioti.
Lo ripeto, sospetto
che sia Johnny Bradfield.
Mi ci vorrà un mese per
scoprirlo, ma vale la pena.
Stupendo. Prenditi due mesi, due anni.
Scrivici cartoline.
- Ah ah ah!
- Ah ah ah. Su. Ridi.
Rideresti pure tu,
se sapessi quanto sei divertente.
Forse lo farei.
Forse riderò fra un po'.
"Guanti usati da Kid Mcneil
quando mise K.O. Sailor O'Shea.
In vendita a 8 dollari."
Portano fortuna.
Potremmo prenderli per Jack
con sette dollari e 60 in più.
Se mia zia avesse i
baffi, sarebbe mio zio.
Ah ah ah!
Ehi, guardate laggiù!
Guarda che macchina!
Chi c'è dentro.
Aspetta. Ho un'idea. Andiamo.
Guarda. Non è carino?
Ehi, cos'è quello?
È vivo.
Ehi, amico, come ti chiami?
J. Douglas Williamson.
Uh uh!
E tu come ti chiami?
J. Montmorenci Spit jr.
Dove l'hai tirato fuori, ragazzo?
Dimmi. Che ci fai qui?
Ci siamo fermati per riparare una gomma.
Andremo via appena papà e "mater"
torneranno dal telegrafo.
Oh, non resterà. Mi si spezza il cuore.
Cos'è una "mater"?
Una "mater" è sua madre, tonto.
Non leggi libri?
No.
Pensi di essere intelligente?
Ci chiamano i 6 geni.
Che tipo di macchina è?
È una motion-picture camera.
Fammi vedere.
La restituirò.
Sì sì. So cosa stai pensando.
Beh, è un gioco da ragazzi.
Dobbiamo farlo onestamente,
o Jack non vorrebbe.
Oh, sì, sì.
Ehi Angel.
Andiamo. Lasciami vedere.
Tieni le mani lontane
da quella macchina .
Ehi. Ti piace?
Andiamo, banda. Dobbiamo agire.
- Vuoi venire, ragazzo?
- Dove?
Oh, andiamo a giocare.
A biglie?
Biglie. È un gioco da femminucce.
Noi giochiamo a poker.
Sai giocare a poker?
No.
Oh. Potremmo insegnarti. È molto facile.
Non abbiamo tempo per
insegnare ai principianti.
Eh, è troppo piccolo, comunque.
Ma ho 12 anni, e potrei imparare.
Bene, cosa ne dite, banda?
Dovremmo lasciarlo venire?
Certo. Perché no?
Dai, Douglas.
Esci subito. Di qua.
Ho solo 25 centesimi.
Oh, va bene, ragazzo. Non hai bisogno
di soldi per giocare a Strip poker.
- Cos'è lo Strip poker?
- Lo scoprirai.
Ho 6, 7, 8, 9 e 10.
Non sono buone?
No.
No. Tieni il 10. Cercheremo
qualcosa di meglio.
Ehi, Dippy.
Quattro carte per Douglas jr.
Dammene 3.
Sono buone?
Bene, è una cosa fra te e Angel ora.
Cosa hai, Angel?
Ho due 7.
I miei sono tutti dello stesso seme.
Sì, sì, lo sono, ma non
c'è una coppia.
La coppia di 7 di Angel vince.
Oh, ora capisco.
Devi avere delle coppie.
Sicuro. Lo capirai bene.
Sì. Douglas jr., puoi togliere
cappotto e cintura.
- Oh, vuoi dire che ho perso, allora?
- Non hai vinto.
Forse li rivincerai alla prossima mano.
Basta metterlo laggiù.
Non lo spiegazzare.
Puoi riprenderlo
in un'altra mano più tardi.
Ehi andiamo.
Sbrigati. Ti stiamo insegnando qualcosa.
Dai. Sbrigati con quelle carte.
- Ho una coppia stavolta.
- Certamente.
Serviti. Stiamo bene così.
Me ne vado
Ne prendo 3.
Prese.
Cos'hai, Tommy?
Solo una misera coppia di due.
Vinco, no?
No. Lui ha due. Tu solo uno.
Leva le tue mani. Va tutto bene,
Douglas. Stai già imparando.
Non ci è voluto molto, vero tesoro?
Douglas!
Cosa è successo?
GASPAR RUTCHEK CONTRO
GLI SFIDANTI
JOHNNIE KALUTCHEE RANDY SMITH
JACK DORNEY
- Tutto bene?
- Eh? Sì.
Il dottore ha detto che sono a
posto al 100%. Peso 69,4 chili.
Ascolta bene. Se entro prima
io sul ring, non tirerai un colpo.
Vorrei sentirmi così anch'io.
Quello che si fa
per i soldi, non è vero?
Ehi, aspetta un attimo.
Per cosa combatti?
- Mia moglie sta per avere un figlio.
- Sì?
È dura, vero?
- Buona fortuna.
- Grazie.
- C'è ancora qualche posto per domani?
- Sì. Qualcuno.
- Dove sono?
- Quanto vicino li vuoi?
Più vicino possibile.
- Beh, che ne dici del bordo ring?
- Ottimo.
Di', questo Jack Dorney
è un mancino?
Non ho idea, signore.
Sono 3 dollari e 30, per favore.
- Ok.
- Grazie.
- Ehi, pensi che ne servano altri?
- No, non servono.
Lo sai, sei un uomo morto.
Acqua, acqua dappertutto.
Ehi, è passato! È passato!
Ha superato la visita medica.
A pieni voti.
- Come lo sai?
- Cy Kimball me lo ha detto.
È appena arrivato in camion.
Il dottore ha detto che Jack
non può stare meglio di così.
Eccolo che arriva. Andiamo.
Sorpresa!
- Adesso? - Sì. - Ok.
Silenzio!
Campione, a nome della banda e mio,
e della nonna e Peggy,
cogliamo l'occasione del
grande incontro per
farti questo regalo, come piccolo segno
della nostra stima.
Ecco.
Discorso! Discorso, campione.
Guardate. Mi dispiace
che abbiate fatto questo.
Vedete,
io non posso combattere
Il dottore mi ha bocciato.
Qualcosa non va al cuore.
Andiamo ragazzi.
Andiamo.
Andiamo. Andiamo.
Qual è il problema?
Sanno che menti, Jack.
Chi, io?
Hai superato quella visita medica.
Senti, Peggy. Lo ripeto. Il dottore...
Cy Kimball era qui e ci ha
detto del dottore.
Va bene. Sono un codardo.
Non lo sei.
Sono un bugiardo,
mi è mancato il coraggio.
Lascia perdere.
Jack, dimmi una cosa.
Mi hai mentito quando mi
hai detto che mi amavi?
No. No.
Cosa c'entra questo?
Tutto.
Perché quando ami qualcuno,
non gli menti.
Non nascondi nulla.
Di cosa parli? Nascondere cosa?
Ascolta.
Ascoltami, Jack.
Ti amo anch'io,
e so che non sei uno che molla.
C'è qualcos'altro.
Sì. Sì sì sì, è giusto.
Qualcosa di nuovo.
Ho sentito parlare di un bel
lavoro, vedi, e stavo per...
Non era una mia idea l'incontro?
Bene, ho cambiato idea.
Quel tipo è troppo grosso. Troppo duro.
Non sono un fesso, ecco?
Perché dovrei rompermi la testa se posso
fare soldi in un altro modo? Tutto qui.
Lasciami in pace, ti prego?
Jack.
Vuoi lasciarmi in pace?
Ha dato un' occhiata a quella
mezza sega e ha rinunciato.
Gli è mancato il coraggio.
Succede così talvolta.
Non se hanno quel che serve.
Non ha coraggio. Non ha coraggio
È un codardo.
Sta zitto.
Jack non ha paura di nessuno.
Oh, no. Jack non ha paura.
Non tanto...
Sta zitto!
Oh, lascialo stare.
Certo che ha paura.
È proprio un vigliacco.
Che verme,
mettere di mezzo il suo cuore.
Jack.
Vai via, Jack?
Perché?
Oh niente.
Se vai via... la proposta di
venire con te è sempre valida.
Scordatelo, ragazzo.
Nessuno viene con me.
Ho pensato che forse...
Non ho bisogno di nessuno.
Io...
Io viaggio da solo
Sì.
Sì, certo, Jack.
A me non importa cosa dicono
i ragazzi e le donne.
- So che non hai paura di lui.
- No, non ce l'ho.
- Non hai paura di nessuno. Lo so.
- Sta zitto. Smettila.
Non ti arrabbiare, Jack.
Quello che volevo dire era
che, se ti decidessi...
Sì. Ho cambiato idea.
- Devi avere le tue ragioni.
- Certo che ho le mie ragioni.
Suppongo che siano valide,
se è così che pensi.
Quello che sto cercando di
dirti è che vengo con te
se vuoi portarmi con te.
Eh, chi sta andando via?
Non stai andando via?
Resto qui.
Combatterai?
Tu che pensi?
Era uno scherzo.
Era uno scherzo. L'ho sempre saputo.
- Aspetta che lo dica ai ragazzi.
- Forza. Dillo. Dillo a tutti!
Che dici, padre?
Supponiamo che lui non vedesse
un mancino sul ring.
Non sarebbe così sicuro che
io sia Johnnie Bradfield,
O no?
I vostri biglietti.
Lui ha i biglietti.
- Sono con lui.
- Biglietti.
Biglietti. Biglietti
Biglietti.
Ehi! Ce ne sono solo due qui.
Dove sono gli altri?
Quali altri? I miei sono solo due.
1, 2. 1, 2. 1, 2. Questo è tutto.
- Jim, controlla l'entrata.
- Sicuro.
Laggiù. Ci sono buoni posti laggiù.
Ehi, ragazzi!
Che cos'ha signore?
Non hai il biglietto.
Chi non ha un biglietto?
Cos'è questo, legno?
Permesso.
Ehi, ragazzi.
- Con questi combatterò?
- Sì. Stringi loro la mano.
Lui non stringe la mano.
La mostrerà sul ring.
Ehi, vieni qui, tu.
Fammi vedere le tue mani.
Ok.
Di', aspetta un minuto.
Non siamo sul ring.
Scherza...
Vieni qui.
Vieni qui. Qual è il problema?
Hai paura?
No. Non ho paura di nessuno.
Bravo.
Ehi, stai calmo, eh?
Sta solo scherzando.
È solo un bambinone, tutto qua.
Ehi, tu. Vieni qui.
Qual è il tuo peso?
69,4.
69,4?
Togli le tue mani sporche.
Conosco questi metodi.
- Sei un pugile, eh?
- Non sono un pugile.
Perché vuoi affrontarmi?
Ho visto la tua foto e non potevo
lasciarti solo.
O sì?
Va via.
Vieni. Smettetela. Cosa c'è?
Lo voglio per primo.
Avanti. Portalo via.
Sei pazzo?
Ora quello ti farà a pezzi in un round.
Questo è quello che pensi tu.
Buh! Buh! Buh!
Che sega!
- Tutto a posto. - Sono pronti.
- Magnifico.
Non tu. Ha cambiato idea.
Andiamo, Kalutchee, ti aspettano.
Ho capito. Cerca di innervosirmi.
Ammorbidiscilo per me.
Andiamo, Lynch.
Abbiamo bisogno di te su.
Sta facendo aspettare anche me.
Sicuro. Ha paura di te.
Pensi così? Veramente?
Sicuro.
Lo gonfio.
Dai. Siediti.
Calma. Che c'è?
Sei in pena per tua moglie?
Starò su finché non ho
pagato il conto dell'ospedale,
O io... forza. Vuoi sederti?
Coraggio. Coraggio.
Mi chiedo che fa Kalutchee.
Lo scopriremo presto.
Il toro non ha
paura dei tipi come lui.
Non ha paura dei picchiatori.
Ha paura dei pugili.
Sicuro.
Non lasciarti innervosire, ragazzo.
Oh, non mi sta preoccupando.
Cos'è?
Deve essere Kalutchee.
- Credi?
- Sicuro.
Vedi? Questo succede a
non mantenere la distanza.
Dovrebbe stargli lontano. Questo farò,
a meno che tu non vada per primo.
Lasciarlo avanzare.
Boxare. Boxare. Colpirlo.
Colpirlo arretrando.
Questo farò... lo gonfierò, a meno
che tu non vada per primo.
Il prossimo si prepari.
Senti. Dov'è Kalutchee?
L'hanno portato via. Tutto rotto.
Vedi? Questo succede a
non mantenere la distanza.
Sì sì. Lo so.
Ok. Ok. Andiamo.
No, non tu, ragazzo. Lui vuole Smith.
Chi, io?
Cerca ancora di innervosirmi, eh?
Pronto, ragazzo?
Beh, sì, ma, beh, no.
Ho solo una mano bendata.
Ok. Sistemeremo
l'altra sul ring. Andiamo.
Bene, tutto bene, Dorney?
Ehi non avrai paura?
Io? Gli gonfierò le orecchie.
Le sue orecchie sono di sopra. Forza.
Buona fortuna, ragazzo.
Destro alla mascella, un sinistro in
viso. È un assassino. È micidiale.
Il toro sferra un terribile destro alla
mascella, e Smith va giù.
Si può capire se resta giù
perché questo è un vero omicidio.
La faccia di Smith è rossa,
rossa, rossa, spappolata.
8, 9, 10!
Smith è K.O.
Sono contento che sia finita.
Ora, il prossimo sfidante per il toro,
Jack Dorney.
Ehi! Eccolo! È Jack!
Vai, Jack! Forza, Jack!
Dai, Jack!
- Jack!
- Jack.
Eccoci qui! Qui! In quarta fila!
Ah ah!
Jack gliela farà vedere a quel gorilla.
Non lo so, nonna. È tanto duro.
Bene, lo è anche Jack.
Non l'ho allenato io?
Attaccalo! Atterralo...
Chiedo scusa. Chiedo scusa.
Oh, Jack gli gonfierà le orecchie. Ah!
Fate bene a urlare!
Sarà finita in un minuto!
Te la faccio vedere io!
Ehi, Johnnie.
Ehi, Johnnie!
Ehi, c'è uno che ti chiama.
Sì?
Come stai, Johnnie?
Lo conosci?
No. Mai visto in vita mia.
Silenzio! Silenzio prego!
L'ultimo sfidante per il toro selvaggio.
Jack Dorney!
Andiamo ragazzi.
Andiamo, andiamo.
Vi batterete secondo le regole.
Nessun colpo basso, nessuna trattenuta.
Stringetevi le mani ora e combattete.
Andiamo, Johnnie.
Colpiscilo, Jack! Colpiscilo!
Non farti colpire!
- Silenzio!
- Silenzio te.
Rutchek fa muovere
Dorney per tutto il ring.
Lo colpisce con un destro
e lo mette alle corde.
"Jack gli gonfierà le orecchie."
Così, Jack!
Colpiscilo! Colpiscilo, Jack!
Allo stomaco! Allo stomaco!
Il sinistro! Il sinistro!
Usa di più il sinistro!
Dai. Combatti.
Non permettere a quel gorilla
di farti questo, Jack!
Colpiscilo! Colpiscilo!
Chiedo scusa.
Va all'angolo. Il toro lo segue.
Colpisce con il sinistro.
Scuote la testa di Dorney.
Sferra un tremendo destro
alla sua mascella,
ora un sinistro alla mascella, e
un altro destro alla figura.
E Dorney è giù.
In piedi, Jackie, ragazzo mio!
In piedi!
Oh, deve essere scivolato.
Sopra un gancio destro alla mascella.
Jack, alzati!
Per favore alzati, Jack!
7, 8,
9.
Picchialo! Picchialo!
Fallo secco! Chiedo scusa.
Tempo.
Qual è il problema, stai
diventando morbido?
Finiscilo ora, ragazzo.
Finiscilo.
- Scommettici. L'incontro non è
ancora iniziato. Vedrai. - Vedrò.
Vuoi chiudere quella boccaccia?
Adesso sistemalo!
Ecco di nuovo il toro. Ha
messo Dorney all'angolo.
Ganci sinistri e destri al corpo.
Scuote Dorney con
un terribile uppercut destro.
Ecco. Dorney va giù per un
terribile destro alla mascella.
Alzati, Jackie!
Alzati! Mi senti?
Non ho sentito qualcuno dire
che ha allenato quella schiappa?
6, 7.
È in piedi! È in piedi!
Ma non per molto.
Vagli addosso con il sinistro, tu...
Jack, farò di te un grande pugile
se quello non ti uccide.
Non so se avrò bisogno
di un manager o no.
Questo ci costa solo 1.500 dollari.
Pensi che sia poco?
- La campana l'ha salvato.
- "La campana l'ha salvato."
Se lo abbattevi al primo,
niente campane.
Ti va di combattere?
Se questo fa un altro round,
paghi tu, tenerone, non io.
Jack! Resisti!
Ma lui va giù. Sicuro.
Non lascerai che quella
schiappa ti batta,
sei tu, Johnny?
Dai. Non tirarla per le lunghe
Tira fuori il destro
e colpisci col sinistro.
So chi sei, mancino. Non mi inganni.
6... 7...
8... 9...
- Mancino, eh?
- Sì!
Cosa ti avevo detto?
Ah, fai silenzio.
Dillo di nuovo.
Fai silenzio.
Bravo, Jack. Ce l'hai fatta.
Vai, ragazzo. Fila.
Andiamo. Vattene tu, sapientone.
Forza, Jack. Forza.
Abbiamo i soldi. Puoi fermarti.
Non ancora.
Sei ferito, Jack,
non ci servono più soldi.
- Ce ne servono ancora. Vai. Sparisci.
- Ma, Jack, sei tutto...
È duro col sinistro.
Qui. Prendi un po' di questo.
Alzati, Jack, alzati.
Per favore alzati!
5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10!
Cosa ne pensa, dottore?
Beh, ne ha prese tante,
ma ne uscirà bene.
Jack.
Jack, stai bene?
- Come sta, dottore?
- Più o meno lo stesso
Oh, Jack! Alzati, hai sentito? Alzati!
Ha provato con l'aceto?
Abbiamo fatto tutto il possibile.
Non sta facendo molto con quella
stupida trombetta alle orecchie, sa?
Jack! Riprenditi, per favore!
Jackie. Jackie svegliati.
Jackie. Va tutto bene.
Ascolta. Lui ha fatto tutto per noi.
Si è fatto uccidere solo per noi
Oh, Jackie. Va tutto bene, caro.
Abbiamo i soldi.
Oh, la mia testa.
Forza, Johnny.
Mi chiamo Jack.
- Chi è lui?
- Oh, è solo un mio amico.
Oh ragazzo. Hai combattuto
una buona battaglia. Lo sai.
Che incontro!
Io dico: chi ha un destro migliore?
- Come ti senti, Jack?
- Mi sento bene.
Che ti avevo detto?
Solo una mancanza di fiato.
Dagli un'altra possibilità con quello,
e lo batterebbe, non è vero, Jack?
Io devo andare ora.
Partire?
Voglio dire, mi devo vestire.
Andiamo, ragazzi. Forza. Fuori di qui.
Ci vediamo al ranch, Jack.
Andiamo! Andiamo! Andiamo!
- Ti aspetto fuori.
- Bene.
Vai. Ti chiamerò.
Stai bene. Dai. Vestiti.
Sarò corretto con te, Phelan.
Jack, stai bene adesso?
Sì. Sto bene. Sto bene.
Puoi aspettare solo un secondo, Phelan?
Devo dire a Peggy qualcosa.
Va bene. Fai presto.
Andiamo. Voglio parlarti, Peggy.
Non scherzo. Mi ha organizzato due
incontri a est. È il mio manager.
- Questo è tutto. Sinceramente.
- Mi stai mentendo, vero, Jack?
No, no.
Mi sta mentendo, no? Mi dica la verità.
No. Credimi, non sto mentendo.
È il mio manager, no?
Certo, sono il suo manager.
Nell' Est ha organizzato tanti incontri
per me. Sono dei soldi facili,
poi tornerò da te.
Sinceramente, lo farò.
Fra circa 10 anni.
Sta solo scherzando, tutto qui.
Ogni pretesto è buono
per fare una battuta.
Se si comporta davvero bene,
lo vedrai presto.
Vuole che faccia un tour in provincia.
Sai, una serata e cose del genere?
Ma non fa per me. Io torno da te.
- Io vengo con te.
- No, no. Non puoi.
Sì.
Non puoi perché... perché, beh...
È una cosa da uomini.
- Non è vero, Phelan?
- Eh? Sì. Niente donne.
Qualcosa non va, Jack.
Che cos'è? Dimmelo, ti prego.
No. Non c'è niente che non va.
Tornerò da te. Lo giuro.
Non mi importa se hai fatto
qualcosa di sbagliato, tesoro.
Io resto con te.
Devi restare con la nonna e i ragazzi.
Andiamo, figliolo. Dobbiamo andare.
Non verrò alla Stazione
con te, Jack...
Dammi solo un bacio e vai via subito
Perché se non lo fai,
farò un macello.
Portami con te, Jack.
Portami con te, Jack!
Sai, Phelan, saresti diventato un grande
detective se avessi iniziato prima.
Non mi lamento.
Non sai perché oggi non lo sono?
Certo certo.
Quando tornerai,
probabilmente il sindaco ti farà sfilare
a Broadway con coriandoli e tutto.
- Diventerai un pezzo grosso
al commissariato. - L'hai detto.
Dobbiamo viaggiare per 3 giorni.
Posso fidarmi?
- Tranquillo, non ti darò problemi.
Ok. Andiamo. Siediti.
Ciao, Jack.
Cosa intendi con "Ciao?" Vai a casa.
Parti?
Vai via, ragazzo. Non c'è bisogno di te.
Chi sta parlando con te?
Vengo con te?
- Te lo ripeto, vai a casa.
- Portami con te.
- Voglio che vai a casa!
Il signor Phelan e io abbiamo un
accordo privato.
Mi piacerebbe portarti con me,
ma io... non posso.
È un grosso affare.
Non è così?
È vero. Ora vai via, ragazzo.
Vedi, devi tornare indietro
e aprire la stazione di servizio.
Sai, è stata una tua idea.
Quel ragazzo ti ha mitizzato.
Sì.
È un bravo ragazzo.
Per me non fa differenza, sai?
Sono un poliziotto.
Devo fare il mio dovere. - Lo so.
Che mi piaccia o no.
Non sto dicendo che non lo fai.
- Ti darò un consiglio.
- Cosa?
Magee è stato colpito con un destro.
- Sì?
- Sì.
Se ti procuri un buon avvocato, potresti
evidenziare che sei un mancino.
Se avrò un buon avvocato.
Non credo sia mia competenza.
Eccolo.
Bene, andiamo.
Stai lasciando
una stupenda signora, ragazzo.
Mi dispiace per lei. Va bene. Andiamo.
Quello che ho spedito sulla sedia,
che hanno giustiziato?
Aveva una moglie.
Quando quella signora ti ha detto
addio, sembrava lei.
La sua bocca piegata
da un dolore interno.
Quella vecchia signora e i ragazzi
sono sicuri che
tu sia il migliore, vero?
Phelan, tornerei indietro e li porterei
tutti con me, ma non si può, lo sai.
Pensavo: un ragazzo
intelligente come te...
Se non ti fossi intenerito
per la signora ed i ragazzi,
non ti avrei mai trovato.
Sei proprio un fesso.
Dici?
Ma io lo farei di nuovo, sai?
Ora, puoi lasciarmi in pace?
Bene, ho fatto un errore nella mia vita.
Sai, forse ne sto facendo un altro.
Forse ho preso la persona sbagliata.
Può essere... Sì. Forse sì, uomo saggio.
Non ne sono del tutto sicuro.
In carrozza!
Vai, ragazzo. Dattela a gambe!
E tieni lontana dalla
macchina fotografica
quella brutta faccia. Non
vieni bene in foto!
Addio, Dorney!
Addio!
Fesso.
Tommy!
Sei completamente pazzo.
Dove pensavi di andare?
Con te.
Allora andiamo.